[Musica]
[Applauso]
molti di noi pensano che il cibo sia la
risorsa più indispensabile per l'uomo
perché una persona senza cibo non riesce
a sopravvivere in realtà senza cibo si
riesce a sopravvivere circa 20 giorni
senza acqua si arrivano a tre giorni
quattro giorni in realtà uno degli
strumenti dei beni più importanti per
l'uomo e l'aria nello specifico
l'ossigeno
vi racconterò una storia una storia
nella quale sono stato partecipe
purtroppo marzo 2020 ci troviamo brescia
l'ospedale di chiari rimane senza una
serie di dispositivi chiamati valvole
venturi che sono questo oggetto che vi
presento orapi giallo in mano che
servono a collegare una maschera
espiratorio con un ventilatore polmonare
122 pazienti malati cofide solamente una
ventina di loro riuscivano a avere le
cure mediche necessarie perché l'azienda
che produceva queste valvole non eri
grado di realizzarle e fornirle in tempo
utile grazie alla direttrice del
giornale di brescia insieme all'ini
vengo contattato poiché la mia realtà si
occupa di realizzare prototipi prodotti
e abbiamo diverse stampanti 3d funzioni
comunicare mi chiede se con le stampanti
riesco a replicare in qualche modo
questi oggetti ci rechiamo velocemente
in ospedale a chiari recuperiamo uno
degli oggetti questa una valvola
veramente utilizzato dal paziente è
stata stabilizzata
la riportiamo in fretta e furia in
ufficio iniziamo quello che viene
definito il reverse engineering ovvero
ridisegnamo di 3d di questo oggetto e
nell'arco di una giornata andiamo a
realizzare i primi quattro prototipi
stampati in 3d quindi molto molto simili
cosa facciamo riportiamo gli ospedali i
pezzi in ospedale l'ospedale per
mezz'ora in testa quindi vi consegniamo
il medico che dice bene datemi li vado
portava a provare direttamente su un
paziente
stupore generale perché ovviamente
pensavamo che venissero trovati sul
macchinario dopo mezz'ora d'attesa il
medico esce e ci comunica
l'esito positivo in realtà parte con una
parolaccia e questo ci aveva
approfondito
cinque secondi di pausa e poi ci dice
bene funzionano portato male ora cento
preferirò assolutamente bisogno quindi
rientriamo in ufficio accendiamo le
stampanti realizziamo in un centinaio di
pezzi e nell'altro di una giornata con
riusciamo finalmente a consegnare la
domenica mattina circa 100 valvole
all'ospedale di chiari la notizia fa il
giro del mondo ne parlano i giornali
italiani giornali americani e varie
testate giornalistiche
convinti di aver finito il nostro lavoro
al reading riporta a casa i miei ragazzi
e dico bene ora prendiamoci visto che
abbiamo lavorato a venerdì il sabato e
domenica prendiamoci in tre giorni di
pausa e ci risentiamo per quelle di per
ricominciare in realtà per iniziarlo
smart working perché eravamo proprio a
cavallo del primo lotto da
in realtà non passano passano meno di
due minuti cinque minuti che riceve una
telefonata da un medico in pensione il
dottor renato favero un medico di
gardone valtrompia e aveva letto
l'articolo di giornale mi dici
complimenti christian per quello che
avete realizzato è stato bellissimo
secondo me però a breve verranno a
mancare non solamente quelle che voi
avete realizzato quelle formule venturi
ma direttamente delle maschere
respiratorie
o una mezza idea devo venire a parlarvi
è urgentissimo e quindi richiamo alcuni
dei miei ragazzi 4 accettano e lunedì
mattina ci ritroviamo in ufficio in sala
riunioni tutti intorno a un tavolo con
il medico che ci racconta la storia e
quindi comincia dicendo si fanno lezione
di anatomia ci racconta i principi di
funzionamento dei polmoni degli alveoli
della polmonite di come il covip attacca
le vie respiratorie e
d come all'epoca acqua in poco più di un
anno fa
i medici cercavano di curare i pazienti
malati comite
prevalentemente utilizzando una
tecnologia una maschera che male c pap
ovvero a pressione continua positiva
dopo due ore
tira fuori dallo zaino un oggetto questo
una maschera da snorkeling della
decathlon e l'appoggio sul tavolo dice
io sono l'ingegnere quindi non so come
mettere mano a questa cosa ma secondo me
voi siete in grado
buona fortuna convertite la si è
riuscita in una maschera respiratoria in
bocca al lupo appoggia la maschera sul
tavolo e se ne va
questo a noi stimola tantissimo
un medico che ci viene a raccontare
un'idea di questo tipo ci è sembrata
geniale quindi iniziamo a muoverci in
diversi modi alcuni di noi contattano
decathlon grazie a massimo temporelli
entrato in contatto con decathlon ci
comunica di cadro che ha circa 100.000
maschera magazzino ci eravamo agli inizi
di marzo quindi la paura nostra era
sviluppare un progetto che poi non
avrebbe funzionato o comunque che non
poteva essere centrati che perché
mancavano musker non solo si limita a
dirci che hanno 100.000 maschere ma ci
fornisce tutti i file tre bimbe tessari
e una quindicina di maschere per fare
tutti i test e contemporaneamente noi
ingegneri iniziamo a smontare la
maschera studiarla capire come passano i
flussi e alla fine definiamo che
dobbiamo agire sulla parte alta sul
boccaglio e quindi progettiamo e
realizziamo questo oggetto giallo che
ora vedete nelle mie mani chiamato
valvola charlotte che permette di
trasformare questa maschera in maschera
respiratoria nella parte centrale non
collegare un tubo dell'ossigeno nella
parte laterale andiamo a collegare un
filtro doveva riesce quindi la riesce
più lenta del paziente malato ma non va
ad intasare la stanza dell'ospedale e
quindi non rischia di farli ammalare i
medici bene cosa facciamo iniziamo
alcuni prototipi neri li chiamo sempre
stampanti 3d perché la nostra specialità
noi realizziamo 4 chiamiamo all'ospedale
di chiari e diciamo dato che ti abbiamo
aiutato qualche giorno fa nel realizzare
le valvole venturi di cui due per il
bisogno non è che ora lo sappiamo che
sei in crisi
avresti voglia di aiutarci a capire se
un progetto è cambiato in pancia e
interessante funziona oppure no
l'ospedale ci mette assolutamente a
disposizione di intervenite vi diamo
proviamo quindi le provano prima su di
noi poi ce le provano subito oro e
infine su dei pazienti mi dicono
lasciano le per qualche giorno e ti
faccio sapere cosa succede in quei tre
giorni
scoppia il finimondo
da quattro ospedali in crisi in italia 2
brescia e bergamo ci ritroviamo con
tantissimi ospedali ad aver bisogno di
maschere perché giustamente poi il
medico aveva avuto ragione le maschere
vengono e se eravamo partiti con
l'obiettivo di dover realizzare 80 pezzi
ovvero 20 valvola eventi maschere per i
quattro ospedali in crisi
in quei tre giorni all'ospedale di
chiari ci comunica che in realtà il
progetto funziona ma ha bisogno di 100
maschere contemporaneamente la
protezione civile bresciana si chiama e
ci dice christian ho comprato 500
maschere della decade ora ho bisogno di
500 balcone charlotte da lanciare per
poterli distribuire gratuitamente gli
ospedali e li teniamo in crisi perché si
realizzerà 80 pezzi con 56 stampanti che
ne abbiamo noi laniera vanno in grado
realizzare migliaia di pezzi diventava
impossibile
oltretutto la notizia si era diffusa
super velocemente perché la stampa di
nuovo aveva fatto esplodere a notizia e
quindi iniziamo a ricevere diverse
migliaia di richieste di valvole e dei
vari ospedali
la soluzione l'unica condizione che
troviamo utile è quella di creare un
sito o meglio aprire una pagina del
nostro sito caricare online i file
gratuitamente e chiedere i giornalisti
di lanciare un appello e l'appello per a
questo chiunque di voi abbia una
stampante 3d a casa in ufficio vi
preghiamo accendetela vi preghiamo
scaricate il file della valvola ferrotti
iniziata stamparle e donate negli
ospedali più vicini
qua c'è stato un miracolo in meno di una
giornata in meno 24 ore abbiamo avuto
quasi 2 milioni di download del file
il sito è andato in crisi diverse volte
perché non era in grado di reggere tutto
il traffico ma soprattutto ci siamo
accorti di non essere stati d'aiuto
solamente agli ospedali italiani oltre
50 ospedali italiani ma all'estero
il vantaggio di poter spedire un file
scaricare file dal brasile l'india gli
stati uniti
tantissimi sono gli stati con cui siamo
entrati in contatto medici ministri con
soli presidenti
abbiamo toccato credo almeno cessando 70
stati abbiamo in realtà perso il conto
proprio perché lasciando libero gratuito
il file
questo è girato è stato tradotto è stato
con caricato su altre 20 siti abbiamo
avuto circa 22 23 modelli di marmo
nation modo diverso perché lasciare un
file e 3d gratuito ed utilizzabile sul
sito permetteva a chi era in grado un po
di modificarlo anche di ridisegnarlo ci
sono aziende che hanno bonificato in
maniera fantastica
una di queste loro che non lo conoscete
benissimo
e grazie a tutto questo aiuto siamo
riusciti ad arrivare praticamente
ovunque
fortunatamente oggi in italia non
vengono più utilizzate inutilizzata
circa 15mila e tantissime altre
all'estero 35.000 in brasile 30 mila in
francia diverse in uzbekistan germania
portogallo filippine burundi madagascar
canada abbiamo praticamente perso il
conto un terzo e ultimo progetto è stato
quello di riuscire a donare direttamente
delle stampanti 3d per i paesi africani
perché loro avevano maschere volevano
utilizzare il progetto i giuristi
lasciavano le maschere negli alberghi
prima di ripartire per tornare a casa ma
non avevano nessuno potesse stampare ai
loro i pezzi e quindi cosa abbiamo fatto
abbiamo mandato loro delle stampanti ne
abbiamo
gli abbiamo insegnato tramite nei video
corsi a
imparare come si stampa di questi gli ha
permesso di essere indipendenti bene ad
oggi non sappiamo esattamente quante
maschere quante persone hanno utilizzato
il nostro progetto ma siamo sicuri che
sono almeno
186mila
questo c'e valso
diversi premi premio anima 2020
il grifone d'acciaio il
titolo di cavaliere della repubblica del
presidente mattarella ma soprattutto un
premio ambitissimo che pochissimi
italiani al mondo hanno vinto
qualche anno prima di noi la prima vinto
il dalai lama che è il
l'alter ego del premio nobel per
l'impatto sociale il mother teresa
memorial award ecco tutto questo perché
considerate crisi 9 in realtà avrà
stampato siano 300 400 di queste valvole
charlotte il resto l'hanno fatto persone
che nemmeno come siamo più di 26 mila
aziende e makers e persone private hanno
aiutato hanno stampato e hanno
realizzato il 99 per cento del progetto
quello che vi consiglio di non seguire i
soldi di non seguire
i consulenti nessun consulente mi
avrebbe detto parti c'erano rischi
altissimi immaginate il realizzare una
valvola venturi una valvola respiratoria
in otto ore tanto più stampate in 3d
tanto più in uso ospedaliero tanto più
si salvava ma se non funzionava avrebbe
anche ucciso delle persone e quindi
tanta responsabilità che avremmo potuto
non prenderci non eravamo esperti e non
lo siamo
ci è sembrato però molto molto utile
essere metterci in gioco e quindi
metterci gioco ci ha permesso di poter
aiutare ecco quello che vorrei che
passasse questo messaggio
fregatevene di quello che pensano gli
altri se pensate che qualcosa che state
per realizzare è utile almeno ad una
persona fatelo e chiedete aiuto perché
vi accorgerete di quanto le persone sono
disposte ad aiutarvi